burger secure number one
not secured hey everyone joe here i'm
back and today we're making
burgers but not just any burgers we're
making burgers using tools that we found
from
all over the internet so we found seven
different tools and i'm gonna be
evaluating them based on their value
their price and if they actually make
burger making
any easier so i'm gonna do all the work
you guys are here to watch
let's get started so i have all my
burger making gadgets here
let's give it a quick run through see
what we have meat grinder
pretty straightforward made of plastic
but this is going to grind our meat so
that way
we have a comparison point of what it's
like to grind your own burger blend
versus having pre-ground meat we have
this nifty little
burger patty maker comes with these
sheets we got the burger master this is
some sort of silicon
mat pulls apart make your burgers in
here i'm not sure if these are
to make patties if they're used to hold
the burger
we're just gonna have to play around
with this one this little mini
indoor griddle you put your burger in
there get a nice indoor
sizzle sear any time of the year i'm
excited
to use this one we have a butter wheel
they're super cool
it butters the bun for perfect toasting
we got the big boy indoor grill top and
bottom
cooking i mean what more can you ask for
let's see if this
is gonna be totally worth it
first things first here let's grind our
burger meat
obviously you can buy your own burger
meat pre-ground there's nothing wrong
with that but when you're buying
pre-ground
burger meat you're only able to control
the fat content so for today i'm going
to be using
chuck sirloin and short rib
the optimal combination we got our meat
grinder here first thoughts
it's plastic in the restaurant obviously
we would use metal
metal is better for a number of reasons
it does have the suction cup on the
bottom so it should
in theory hold in place comes with this
nifty little tamper
so we're able to push the meat down into
the center i'm
optimistic about this we got to cut our
meat and i'm just
looking for these to be smaller than the
hole that we have here so they don't get
caught up in the grinder so let's get
our grinder
attached to the table and then in order
to keep everything cold and out of the
temperature danger zone
i have a bowl sitting on another bowl
filled with ice and a little bit of
water
starting with our short rib
all right here we go i'm worried this is
going to come flying off the table we're
going to use a little piece of cling
here on top
that's going to direct everything down
into the bowl i'm going to use my other
hand to hold this in place
just in case it feels like it's about to
come undone we're looking good
first piece down switching arms
definitely getting tired build their
little
tamper tool keep our hands safe all
right this is working surprisingly well
the suction cup came undone nothing
broke
we're so good this is a workout you know
what's actually nice about this
the grinder kind of gets stuck go
backwards a little bit and then you go
forward
let's see what we got here we got i mean
it's ground beef you can still see all
the fat
scattered throughout the meat the pink
the white the red the separation
and i feel good about turning this into
burgers let's make some patties
we have a small burger press we also
have the shape and store
burger cutter maker i've never seen
anything like this and i'm kind of
excited to see how this goes what's
interesting about this is that the
burgers are not actually round
i've never made hexagon shaped burgers
i'm not sure maybe once they're cooked
they'll form into circular patties but
this will be interesting i'm not even
going to
preform these i'm just going to help
smear it to the edges
fill up our whole package everybody's
pressed
this is gonna go right on the top it
should cut divide separate form and seal
all of our burgers we're gonna go stick
this in the fridge keep it cold till
we're ready to cook
we have the burger press should in
theory
speed up the burger shaping process
it also comes with these nifty little
pre-cut parchment squares
and that way when you press it all
together it pops right out i'm just
gonna eyeball this i'm gonna guess about
a quarter pound
parchment down first then we can place
our patty meat
then we can go parchment on top and then
we come in with our handle and our tool
now we're just gonna press this down top
comes off
patty comes out look at that it does
remind me of those uh pre-made patties
you would buy frozen if you think you
know how to tell the top of the patty
from the bottom of the patty let me know
in the comments all right
it's not a trick there's a right answer
all right we got patties done we got
patties done
let's start preheating these griddles
and cook some burgers
[Music]
starting with this cute little super
adorable
mini grill i've had it preheating for
about 10 minutes now
and it's still i could touch it but it's
not really a good time for searing
burgers but
you know it's tiny i already know right
off the bat
that other burger press made burgers too
big to even fit in here so i'm not even
gonna try it
but our shape and store burger maker
5000
has smaller sized patties so i think
that's gonna work really well in here
so let's see how this goes
wow i'm impressed
they tear right off i'm going to keep
things simple here and just
use a little bit of salt
we're going to burger right on
we're going to put the top down i'm not
going to push too hard i don't want to
spread it out
we're going to let the natural weight of
the lid do its thing
i'm going to stick the rest of these
aside and wash my hands
while this cooks all right we're
sizzling nicely here our burger's
cooking
in the meantime we can get our butter
wheel set up and ready to go
you need to melt a large amount of
butter
to get it into the wheel in the first
place
so then it has butter down on the bottom
as you turn it
all right well i see some caramelization
on one side that means it's cooking
i'm honestly surprised that we're seeing
like grill marks on this thing
you know if you're like in a dorm room
or somewhere where you don't have a lot
of counter space or maybe you don't have
a stove your studio a hotel room
this could be your tool all right i feel
good about this i think it's time
i'm actually going to flip this on the
opposite side so we take a look
oh all right we got a nicer
caramelization on the top
oh it's hot be careful we're going to go
with our
bun toasting but look at this do a
little rolly action
oh we are buttered we'll go butter side
down it's almost like made for a bun
it's perfect i wonder if i could you
know this might be dangerous
but i live for danger don't do this at
home let's put a warning at the bottom
of the screen
i'm going to take my other half and i'm
going to hold it
against the grill on the top twice as
fast oh
check it out we got grill marks we got a
nice toasty roasty bun
that worked for some reason the top gets
hotter than the bottom the bottom
almost toasted i mean that's pretty good
i'm happy with that we got a burger
let's try the other grill and our other
patties
[Music]
we have our hamilton beach indoor grill
much more space an entire lid to keep
everything contained less mess on the
counter top
we actually have a temperature dial on
this thing here
i have this preheating all the way to
sear i feel i feel heat
we have our patties here we're doing our
larger patties i'm going to just peel
off
our outer parchment a little bit of salt
that's all we're using today
grill feels hot shall we do this let me
go right there
patty two we're gonna go a little salt
on the opposite side
i'm gonna close the lid see how that
works i think that'll also help create a
warmer environment almost like you're in
an outdoor grill
turning this into a hot box oven type
situation
all right i'm ready for a flip flip
number one we have absolutely
no crust on the burger there's a couple
of little grill marks on there but
not ideal it's not the best not the
worst
we could use our little butter roller
here again one of my favorite tools
do a little griddle there buns are
toasting let's grab some cheese
i'm gonna go onto one burger with cheese
we have all of our buns let's take a
look
first round oh beautiful i think we're
just about ready here oh yeah
that's gonna be our plane we're gonna
throw the lid down melt the cheese
you know what we could do maybe this is
cheating maybe it's not i'm gonna do it
anyway i got a little bit of water here
creates steam which helps cheese melt
cheese is melted burger is cooked
we have all of our samples ready to go
all that's left to do is assemble and
taste
we've made it this far we've tested out
almost all of the burger gadgets there's
only one left to try
it is these cozy little burger holders
before we get there i have my burger
toppings here
i'm a big fan of spread it's got the
mustard it's got the pickles
it's got the ketchup it's got a little
bit of mayo got this nice little bib
lettuce
that'll go down on top of the spread
patties next
one thinly sliced tomato last but not
least some thinly sliced onion
totally optional if you want to grill
your onion i support that decision
check that out we just made some burgers
all indoor
looking mighty fine we have these little
burger holders
if there's one thing i would want to
improve these holders is a flat bottom
so that way you can set it down and it
doesn't rock back and forth
but you know let's see what happens and
we might have to smush it just a little
bit to get it to fit
all right secure burger secure number
one
not secured then i squish a little bit
just a little squish not a lot of squish
okay it's a lot of squish which i don't
love i don't like smashing my burger to
get it into a holder
so this is our first burger here this
was cooked on the mini little dash
red oven i'm not upset by that
but you know what i still got spread on
my finger even with the little burger
holder
but all in all beautiful burger now we
gotta try the meat that we ground
ourselves and cooked on the hamilton
beach grill
that's this one right here
i'm telling you grinding your own meat
it's the way to go so much more flavor
even that hand cranked meat grinder that
was kind of a pain to work with
totally worth it now at this point and
you know what
these buns let me tell you with that
butter roller
makes the buns taste quite magnificent
let's
review all of the gadgets that we just
used
i have no idea how much any of these
costs so
we're going to find out in real time and
we'll re-evaluate
based on our criteria the value whether
it actually made
burger making easier and the price
on a scale of one to five let's do our
uh super smasher
5000 what is the price on this
25 that is a rip off i'm gonna rate this
a a two a two only because it worked
if it didn't work it would have been a
one our smash handle
this is sturdy it's metal my guess is
twelve dollars
12.99 12.99 put me on the price is right
four out of five on this one it worked
it was efficient
if you're looking to make a whole bunch
of patties i could see this being useful
moving down the list let's go meet
grinder here my guess
on the price here 34.99 29.95
close okay i want to give it a four it
works it's great it's kind of a pain
but if it was anything more than thirty
dollars it would be a three
our little red dash grill it's still a
little warm
my guess here for this thing 29.99
11.99 11.99 holy look at that
i'm gonna give it a three the price is
great but i mean come on do you really
need a little mini thing like this next
oh our butter wheel
it's efficient it works this is like
what you would find at a restaurant
supply store 18.99
nailed it 5 out of 5 stars next
our big girl did not do a great job with
our caramelization
i'd rather use a pan my guess we're
looking at
i want to say at least 49.99
69.99 for me that's expensive i don't
think that's worth it at all i'm gonna
give it a two it's fine
it's okay but why would you not just use
a pan burger buddies
a four pack has got to be like 4.99 14.
what why i give this a zero zero
and that brings us to the end all of
these burger gadgets we found on the
internet
if you had fun thank you all for
watching i want to know what you want to
see me review
next there's tons of gadgets out there
all over the internet let me know
down in the comments below give me a
follow on instagram or
here on youtube i'm chef joe sasto and
thank you for watching
you